if you could invent a new word what
would that not to put you on the spot
conan but like you know how the germans
have these great words that only they
can come up with to explain
things and [ __ ] i think the japanese
special words like
invade uh
[Laughter]
yeah they have so many words for
basically the same thing
have you ever thought of a new word like
well first of all i'm going to flip this
over to
my co-workers who will attest to the
fact that i don't
use real words in my regular life yes
all i use are nonsense words
and babble i sometimes say whole
sentences and sona you actually speak
pretty good conan don't you
i do yeah and uh you know the other day
you were like uh
you know you had left your glasses and i
was like oh i i found your glasses like
no no no they're da moggle and they're
glasses i
i call glasses dom oglebees which just
yeah yeah and and i'll say like hey
where's my uh
mogglebees and she'll say oh god you
mean your glasses
but a lot of times i'll say where are my
dumb oglebees and she'll say oh they're
right
here and she knows what i'm talking
about so
i refuse to use regular words um
when i was in college i got sick of my
friends coming up to me and
talking to me about their relationship a
guy would come up to me a friend of mine
in college would come up to me and his
name was tom hill and he'd say yeah
my relationship isn't going that well
she and i aren't getting along and i
said don't call it relationship
let's call it a bueno which is the
spanish word for good
and so i actually got a bunch of people
in college
saying uh having trouble with my bueno
oh my god have a little trouble with the
bueno and i actually got people doing it
and whenever i can do that i'm very
happy uh mushit means let's eat so our
producer now jeff
ross comes up to me and says let's mush
it let's go let's mush it
this is good mush and so i am constantly
uh
what a gum gum i use for a lot of things
right sona yeah mostly for your phone so
it's like hey conan here's your gum gum
yes you'll say i found your gum gum i
know that means
and i'll say i can't read my gom gum
because i don't have my dom oglebees and
she knows that that means
or i would have responded to your text
about mushing it
means so you break that down uh i didn't
have my glasses so i couldn't read
my phone and see the text that you
wanted to know when we're having lunch
so
those that's that's me all the time
that's all i do is make up words
it sounds like you do this to get out of
things
well no you know there's actually a
proud irish tradition
joyce made up a lot of words i like to
elevate what i'm doing
to say that uh you know a lot of the
great
irish writers they twisted the
modernists
in in irish literature twisted language
beautifully when they do it it's genius
when i do it it's because
oh conan something's wrong with him you
know
he's why is he so weird no one no one
says oh conan he's the modern
joyce you know yeah vagiroo
um so magoosh
was a company that used to advertise
with us and then they stopped because i
talk about them constantly and they
don't have to pay me any money i don't
even know what magoosh does i'm going to
be honest with you i have no idea i
forgot what magoosh does
but i love saying amagush
it just it gives me so much joy and so
now magoosh needs to become
a word yeah probably for my briefs you
know like
um i need new magoosh you know it's like
it's the briefs that i wear it'll
i'll find a good use for magus wait wait
what my briefcase
so does your cockaroo go in your magoo
you know what
we're trying to keep this clean matt
this okay we're trying to sell this
format to nickelodeon and you just
ruined it
i forgot yeah you forgot you always
forget you know how many nickelodeon
deals
you've blown for us because i've just
about sealed the deal and then you go
where does the cockaroo go and then no
more
we're out